yeah long time no play aqaba in the
house I have played many scotch game
against this guy so let's see what he's
doing is so yeah I really had no idea
what line is going to going to play and
I have to say I really don't have
something great here available this is
night a three stuff sorry it's popular
nowadays how to play that I wonder if
that may be fatigue on it it looks a
little like some some French French
defense here why am I just now maybe I
can just stay here and don't don't
really react you to his setup I
interesting that's not let DM very much
familiar with you ok that chick on d4
you will take c6 yeah I let make some
sense this is the setup if i go here
maybe let's go down Bishop f4 I have
Bishop d6 that looks ok for me I believe
ok yeah ok that it loses some time for
me but it doesn't feel like a huge issue
Bishop to d7 I might have d5 no I have
not
so I can't play that for Bishop c6 yeah
I thought I can just read recapture
actually because I mean Bishop d7 rupee
8b to Aang's ok so just goes back yeah
that looks a lot like a French defense
so let's this like a French Rubinstein
on how is that lower line cord tirage
with them with 95 this is a typical idea
clearing yeah let's do this 96 is not
working no should give wait 55 like an
even level 25 I can also do this right
just wind windows temper for age 6 now
here I he might have Bishop g3 hmm huh
maybe it wasn't such a great idea friend
all right yes I said I'm sorry for the
messages some had toyed around with the
audio setups so much that at some point
I somehow switched ICC has those
messages and normally have the mostly as
switched off but I am some house had had
them switched beg wand so here Bishop g5
are playing Bishop d3 I was thinking I
hope something that night takes is six
is not going to work maybe it is I was
sloppy sloppy move how I mean I had
Queen B 6 awesome
some other continuation yeah Bishop g5
Bishop g3 night is six
he takes is really not very interesting
or comfortable ship there 96mm takes
Queen takes not not good not really good
now I'm losing a pawn at the end of this
this procedure at ete takes this also
terrible come on let's take them and see
if I have some some kind of defense here
yeah i blundered that blundered into
that
j queen cakes it's too bad yeah hey
Keegan I can just yeah he can just do
this of course okay that was this just
badly play stumbling into this stuff and
I see that I saw that it was possible
just just too late okay so you can
always hope to draw the rook endgame
please the remaining pawns are not we go
anything like that I can check me now
anyway my time is check is running low I
have to have to play reasonably quickly
in Luke endgames you always have some
hope almost in almost all cases there
will be some chances to tie rod yeah
it's not not easy here admittedly he
also has no weaknesses and it makes it
difficult
48 seconds eyelids yep check I what I
came I really check just have to hope
was some kind of mistake check trading I
came he avoids the trade yes it's a good
decision yeah I wanted to trade quite
clearly
you can form
check
try and forget for if you makes an
unfortunate move King a six or something
check
check
check
check
hmm might still be lost but it wasn't
particularly great technique I had to
Los drank far too too too far away here
ok let's resign that plan now that
wasn't there was a bad game bad game
played by me here I was seeing that idea
oh yeah I'm quite comfortable not much
not much happening and I look T 5 here
really that was simple and good right
threatening this to win apiece yes to
play Bishop g5 them ooh ok there any way
that also wasn't wasn't bad I just um I
just played terrible stuff ok h6 was a
bad idea already i can go 95 here that's
much better and totally ok or i also
have that idea which just gives me
better with the bishop am yeah but there
was a bad idea really and now i have to
play the Queen Queen move somewhere so I
actually can play that check that that's
the real plan I saw that but ok jack
yeah you know what my problem was I was
thinking that here I have to play Bishop
of seven but the computer just says that
this is equal ha check check basically
stating that after that here White has
no no attack whatsoever they have care
that's difficult to see sangria killed
the way it went I really was just a porn
down
check and well you can always fight but
its own check check check it's very
difficult check still Philip you
probably played it well always keeping
keeping some advantage maybe it's in
with hindsight would have been better
not to play G fire but it's pretty
rotten my chances were earlier in that
game thanks for watching